summertime means traveling for so many
families including the pets from planes
to hitting the roadways we have you
covered on how to travel
safely with your four-legged friend
christian kossarus showing us
how to get ready to travel that's right
brian well it's no surprise pet owners
will
go that extra mile to travel with their
dog or with their cat
so we found some ways to make traveling
easier with your pets
as well as some options if they have to
stay behind
she's world travel that literally has a
european passport
yeah she travels everywhere we get a
room
that takes dogs and i welcome you know
and take them to the beach or wherever
we're going
traveling with your pets can be fun but
it can also get complicated
according to a survey by the american
pet products association
67 percent of households own a pet and
the u.s
travel association reports 37 percent of
pet owners
like carrell bully take their animals
when they travel
she's harnessed in the front seat to
because just like kids they you know
they can fly around the car and you
don't want that to happen
when you're hitting the road remember
safety when you need to add the water
it makes a little both kendra george
with petsmart shares some advice for the
trip dehydration is one of the
most things to really be tentative to
when traveling
we also do like harnesses that would be
able to strap to like their cars
we have car seats as well for dogs
if they're more larger you know they may
be getting something
like a cooling pad in the back
if you're flying keep in mind airlines
have different policies and fees
most allow only dogs and cats you must
also provide
current vaccinations for traveling by
pain playing i would say maybe doing
like uh giving them some supplements or
like maybe asking your vet to prescribe
um maybe some like anti-anxiety
medication
as well but if things get complicated
remember there are several options
around the valley like day cares and
overnight boarding
i found this spot in the southwest
valley this is our individual yard
jason mccallum of adventure pet resort
says his business is equipped with
cameras
on-site training even grooming we have
in common
all the time dropping off for just a few
hours to the whole day you know
uh literally up to 12 hours and since we
are 24 hours
we work a lot with the medical industry
kennels or sweets your pooch will be
pampered
while you're away i wouldn't travel
without her she's the best little
traveling companion i could ever have
and
you know traveling is stressful and and
you know she does help relieve it plus
she brings
so many smiles
i think she was smiling there well
remember trains and buses also have
their own pet policies but best advice
don't forget about your pets
while you're planning that next getaway
on your computer maybe on your phone
those last minute arrangements can get
pricey christian gossett is 8 news now